I had a little bit of a fling with a
Burmese girl mm-hmm in college my
freshman year and she was outstanding
[ __ ] outstanding real [ __ ] she was a
naughty girl just not a girl they
usually are and you know I do that do I
know the truth I might hear the story
what is a man she was uh tiny she was
tiny and to the pond was like geez my my
dick is you know and you know I do I do
fairly well down there as you know yes
not bad
she hit me with she goes what balls and
dick no I got dead more balls though but
I got a dick on me yeah but if there's
like you listen yeah if you're on the
witness stand and kids are dumb enough
identified to dick I think you're
Michael Jackson it's a huge balls right
and then I bet that's not true and you'd
be like bummed out and then foo boom do
you have a gold ring attained balls well
I got em he got a good-sized dick but
the outliers are nuts but she grabbed my
dick when it was Tana
oh yeah and she was so cute and small oh
wow I know did you say small I've never
had I was like that's not true you're
tiny she goes oh my other boyfriend my
boyfriend was had the biggest taken him
I was like what how big was it because
is he black uh I don't know I didn't ask
well I didn't ask how old were you at
the thing I was uh I was 11 years old
and I remember no I was a 18 I was 18
maybe my dong grew I guess you dick I
wanted you to get the yeah ding supposed
to get as smaller as you get older what
ya inverts like a turtle something like
that unless you put it to use the way I
do huh you know because I I'm done
growing I'm not gonna get taller does
your dick the same way like at what ages
stop girl her nose and ears keeping your
dick
I'd say once she hit puberty it's over
that thing doesn't grow anymore
look at how Google the answer is all
that question 18:19 your penis isn't
likely to grow much longer or thicker
thicker so you're stuck with what you
got at 19 bro
i I don't know I think I had a growth
spurt but not your boy you ball
all day long it grew and then I think no
one like in gym class as soon as i
carrying all the balls it's like this
big bad gravity working a bag yeah yeah
I got some balls it's not a bad problem
to have dude I was loved because I was
looking at trying to look up the
Internet
Luke Rockhold was at my house to see
trying looked up the Internet yeah Luke
Rockhold is like drinking coffee and I'm
and I leaned down a look at the Internet
to get it for him it's a code and that's
I'm Lina I'm naked and and he takes a
[ __ ] picture like an [ __ ] with
balls of me squatter yeah you just see
my balls it's just like I was like
you're such a dick just my my heavy sack
yeah it looked horrible
yeah looks like I was pulling it wasn't
me mr. sack it was just a card angry
dark sack yeah they get dollar pins well
then you are root yeah what are you men
thanks buddy that it's in just one one
more good news is high art well I know
you do a podcast should I listen to it
when women ask me I literally like
sometimes I get a woman is like 40 and I
go don't listen you don't listen to it
real like oh no no no host is appalling
yeah yeah no it's like they're trying to
go into a room where there's an orgy no
no I'm telling you it was some dude I'm
like a god if he's a cop or he's like
I'm like yeah we'll listen you'll love
it right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]